space the final frontier we're all
fascinated by human attempts to reach
faraway galaxies but going out into
space also gives us a unique perspective
to see the planet Earth and measure it
in ways we cannot do from here
one very important field which relies
more and more on space technology is
climate action
I'm here with vice-president of the
European Commission mal Shaff Javitch
and three experts who are making smart
use of space tech for fighting climate
change we will hear from them but most
importantly we would like to hear from
you we are now simultaneously live on
the main accounts of the European
Commission on Facebook Twitter and
YouTube and on the vice president's
LinkedIn account during this
conversation I invite you to leave your
comments questions and suggestions and I
will try to bring as many of your voices
to the vice president and the panel is
always on equipped with a tablet to look
at your comments here's your chance to
ask or pitch your best ideas to those
who shape the future of Europe space and
climate policies so let me quickly
introduce our four guests in the studio
as I said now chef Javitch vice
president of the european commission in
charge of the energy union and the EU
space strategy we have pfaffenbach is a
senior scientist of the European Centre
for medium-range weather forecasts which
is running the Copernicus Climate Change
service if you're last that's okay we
will explain what this is all about in a
moment
Franchesca LaRosa is a researcher at the
Euro Mediterranean center on climate
change and co-founder of pan and shift
energy elite scandal
director and of research and development
at vortex so now we know who we are I'd
like to start with you vice president
you've done this kind of crowd sourcing
of ideas before but this time we have a
very specific question that we'd like to
ask on space and climate why these two
and why now I think that we are really
very lucky with the timing because we
have actually very special time or
they're going on not only I just came
back from the climate summit from cup 24
from Qatar we'd say but at the same time
I know that there are very intense and
interesting discussions going on in
Marseille we have a space figure I know
that our participants took part in the
discussion and I think the Europeans
should be also very proud that just 10
days ago we presented
to the whole world and I was very glad
to bring that message to cut of it say
how can we make our economy climate
neutral as of 2050 and I know that we
need all technologies on board and I
think that space and space technology
would be key to achieve it to have
better monitoring to really know what's
happening on our planet and to have much
better picture what we humans did to
Mother Earth and how we should correct
it so therefore I'm glad that I have
young innovators and researchers with me
because I'm sure they can present it
even in a more plastic vision and
picture than I can do so let's see what
it is that they are doing I'll start
with you FEA explain to us so you're
working for one international
organization but you're also working on
the climate service of Copernicus how
does that work so if we start with
Copernicus say for those who don't merit
it's a huge new program that's a
dedicated to space so it contains the
space segment which is about satellites
they're very Mays cutting-edge
satellites for observing the earth but
in addition to this program with the
satellites they're also number of
services to make sure that the data we
get from these satellites is actually
used by as many as possible across
Europe but also across the world because
the data is free and open and the
climate change service uses this data
from the satellites but also data from
past outlays missions but also from data
from actually ground-based data sets but
also models to bring information to wide
audience to make more climate smart
decisions correctly the EU shoots
satellites into space you guys come in
you take the data that the satellites
manage to collect on earth and you
process them in a way that anybody can
then use yes the idea is to participate
the satellite data to let's say look at
what sea level rise has been since the
start of the satellite era or a little
bit later in the case of sea level but
also to combine this kind of information
into computer models much like we do for
weather forecasts for instance but do
you look back in time
and then we have a record not only of
what a satellite has seen but also a
combined record that gives us an idea of
the past date of the climate but also
the current state to now plug into the
data that comes from the EU satellites
what do I need to do you can you can
also process the data online because
that's one of the big issues I think
with satellite data it's has huge
quantities so for some this is you know
process that but for some you really
need a processing step in between not
only for knowledge process say to say
but also actually data reduction process
you might go back to the question of
cloud services for smaller companies
that don't have the processing power but
I don't want to lose audio ends that are
now hearing big words and don't
understand what we're talking about you
told me that it was easy to get the data
from from your website and we have two
cases here of Europeans were actually
making use of your data and I'd like to
turn to you Francesca you develop the
whole business model if I understand
correctly of using this copernica
satellites data what do you do with that
data well as a researcher of course we
use these data and the post-process data
therefore the products that are ECMWF
and the Copernicus climate change
service provide two cutting edge to
provide cutting edge acai research
frontiers but also in terms of business
model and business opportunities this
data and these products can be part of
the vibrant communities where climate
change matters for business because it's
not anymore treads but is turned into an
opportunity and this opportunity can
generate not just new services to
support decision making but also new job
opportunities new technological
advancement what do you do with the data
that you have how do you monetize it how
do you turn it into a business well at
the moment we are in the development
phase because actually we're supported
by the Copernicus accelerator program so
what is the comparing accelerator
program is the program is a scheme that
is funded a European level 450 startup
ideas and concepts to build them
throughout 10 months time in order to
bring them to a market level so we start
we are followed up by your specific
mentor that was assigned to us that
helped us and developed our concept
bringing it into the market so he's not
anymore just a research project but
becomes relevant for market purposes and
you also told me that you're helping
other Italians who want to use that data
so you communicate to them how to best
use the data of the Copernicus data
store because the Copernicus climate
change service launched this initiative
that is called train the trainer's wear
trainers specifically pair countries are
selected to give in-country trainees in
their own language selecting within
their networks to spread the awareness
about this data but also to show how
this data can be helpful gives you a
concept Francesca I don't know how to
handle this data it's too big it's too
complicated come show me it can happen
but normally what you give is a blended
trainer there is composed by webinars
and face-to-face event and during these
activities you're actually in touch with
people with this participant to these
trainings therefore is easier for them
also to interact in terms of solve this
problem and all these initiatives are
coming from Copernicus climate change
service therefore from the European
Union I may be taking one step backwards
from Copernicus the vice president
mentioned the EU space week and I heard
that you took part in some of the
activities you were in Marseille here so
what happened in Marseille this week
what happens is that I so really a
vibrant communities of interpreters and
the vibrant communities of European
activities that are all in a way trying
to communicate and cooperate together
and this is a very important point in my
view fostering the cooperation between
different communities because actors are
actually eager to use climate change
information in order to create new new
opportunities in Marseille there is the
space industry to meet and discuss about
different sectors and different
opportunities and there are also the
Copernicus masters the Copernicus
accelerator of this year and last year
but everything that is connected to the
incubation of new entrepreneurial
realities and of course every Copernicus
service so from land monitoring to the
climate change service as well okay
turning to jail but before I ask you
about what you're doing at vortex there
were a few comments and trying to trace
now of people basically saying what's
the point of sending satellites into
space it's going to be too late by the
time we see that climate change is
happening to do anything about it
others are saying you're just polluting
by sending out Rockets some are not
everyone but I'd like you to explain a
little bit what you're doing with the
data that we get from Copernicus because
I understand that you're trying not just
to see climate change when it's already
done but you're also trying to prevent
it from happening okay yes probably one
of the users from the green energy
industry that has done a lot more data
from Copernicus we what we do is bore
text my company is a software as a
services so we provide access to built
well data win/win resource virtual data
that allows the user from the wind
industry to accelerate the development
of the project so we provide information
about where to where this best site are
located which is the expected wind speed
that you will get which is the launch
arm as wind speed on your project so
what basically what we do is to
facilitate the online platform where
users can get this information from wind
resource mix it on many models but
behind these models there is copper
nickel data that is our main sources for
40 so if I have to simplify you take the
data that you get from fire service you
download it you process it and you
manage to figure out what's the best
place to put a windmill that would be
the most effective to produce clean
energy we provide this information
through an interface to the user from
the industry that they have to take a
decision they use several sources
on-site measurements and also be treated
as the one we provide and you also told
me earlier that you're doing a project
with the World Bank where you're trying
to map the whole world about the best
places to put and windmill is that
correct
yes this is a very important project
developing by the World Bank where they
we are putting in place where is the
World Bank who put in place an interface
a web webpage to map the global
resources and to provide this this data
in an open interface so with the users
from especially from new markets in
developing countries they can have this
information to start developing develop
their projects okay so that's basically
that means that the World Bank's future
map the project that you're working on
will all be using the EU satellites
Copernicus data it's already is the case
we use it one version of the Copernicus
data and next year will be an update
with the newest person of Copernicus
data that has been integrated in our
system so vice-president like to turn
one of the questions we got here from
you this is from Mike Ford who who
posted it on Facebook and he's asking
whether given that we're using the
Copernicus data and different fields
he's mentioning
agriculture and movement of goods and
he's saying shouldn't we have standards
all around the world so that we all use
this data in a way that we can share it
we hear from jail that everybody is
using Copernicus data now but should we
do it in a way that everybody is using
the same standards he's actually for
once proposing that the EU would
regulate standards usually regulated so
that everybody can use that data in the
same way what do you think about that's
the proof that copernica is actually a
big European success because this is
really the best Earth Observation space
infrastructure on this planet that
really like the quality of the data and
the fact that it's used all over the
world and when I'm traveling even to the
United States so very often the nasa
officials are the first one to
congratulate us on the success of
Copernicus and on the quality of data
they are using for the space mission
they are using when they are trying to
take all the consequences of the
different weather related disasters so
this is very important and I'm also very
happy about that aspect of the question
it just demonstrates how the space data
and Copernicus that it could be
universally used and I can tell you that
also in my field of work we use it for
transport we use it for smart grids in
energy networks we use it for
agriculture we can measure if the
forestry management is properly done in
our Member States we see the degradation
of the icebergs and all the I would say
dire consequences of the of that climate
change so that's
the big contribution to really fighting
the climate change and the previous
question which was which was also linked
to to this one that how this of the
Western program is actually helping the
climate change I think we have to know
that to be more precise about the
dimension of climate change
you have certain something like 50
indicators and 35 of them you can get
only thanks to our satellites so you
wouldn't be able to to observe you know
all that sea levels movement acidity of
our seas or overheating of the surface
of Earth and many other indicators which
are so important for really measuring
what's happening with our planet so we
need the satellites to be much more
precise about what's happening on earth
and concerning the the standards of
course that's a ambition of the European
Union that we clearly are leaders in in
this aspect and we would look for the
ways how to make this data even more
available to the common citizens because
I know that computing power is a
challenge and therefore I'm really
thankful to our innovators to make it
it's a more user friendly that we do not
have to go through Google's Amazon than
others to actually have a process data
but they can use the new European
platforms and and European companies to
kind of pre digest it for the for the
final euros because this is I think
where Europe still have to move on and
if the standards help let's do it and I
think that we're in a good position to
start the process certainly ask all of
you what's next with this Copernicus
we're not going to focus on young
Copernicus but we touched upon it so
Copernicus climate are there any future
major milestones that you see in the
horizon can we expect to see even more
of that kind of service or different
services well I think when we're
especially having the cop in mind say
the conference of the parties in Qatar
which at the moment why the discussing
kind of the rule book for how are we
going to implement the Paris agreement
so part of that is a second global
stocktake they're supposed to take a
place every five years the first one in
2023 and and part of that is reporting
from individual nations
you know we've emitted this much
carbon dioxide and so on and so forth
but what I think is needed when and what
is planned as a initiative as part of
Copernicus is to have a carbon dioxide
monitoring service which lets us
estimate how much how many well the
human emissions of carbon dioxide so if
I understand correctly right now
Copernicus can already detect different
greenhouse gases but now you would like
to be able to plug into what the leaders
of the of the world are doing this week
and Katowice and the Paris agreement and
you would like to be able to provide
them with data that would help them
monitor the implementation of the Paris
agreement well yeah and monitoring also
verify the reporting so there are
already satellites in place not
necessarily European ones that measure
co2 so carbon dioxide concentrations in
atmosphere but it's relatively complex
because we know we have emissions but
not only humans emit carbon dioxide but
you also have vegetation it also comes
from the oceans
it's not just because a cow exactly but
you also have natural emissions from
forests but they also take up right so
your challenge is to distinguish between
the two and say this is what we humans
did and this is the rest what we humans
do we can limit the rest is natural so
this is something that I understand that
Copernicus is intends to do in the
future I happen to have a short video to
explain in 25 seconds what it is that
you're planning to do in a few years can
we show it now here it is Copernicus the
European Union's Earth observation
program plans to build a support
to consistently monitor anthropogenic
co2 emissions combining in situ and
satellite observations with detailed
models of the atmosphere and biosphere
the proposed sentinels will have better
performance and coverage than current
satellites to achieve worldwide
monitoring of co2 emissions so
vice-president that sounds too good to
be true what needs to happen in order
for us to see it actually in operation
I think the phrase right that the thrust
of the negotiations in Qatar it's right
now is how to improve the monitoring how
to make sure that people have what is
called among the diplomas a single
rulebook meaning that we would have much
more precise information about how the
countries are actually respecting their
commitments to which they sign up in
Paris and how actually they are
implementing them in real life so until
now we are very much relying on the
paper reporting and I think that the
first information we are getting from
our satellites is helping us to see you
know if we are delivering or not but to
get to that more precise level of
monitoring and verification we would
need new satellites up there
the satellites for Copernicus program
which would be of the new generation
which would have that ability to
distinguish between natural emissions
and man-made emissions because I think
that would be very very crucial for
their for the future so if you need to
get a good budget for the next seven
years for our space programs which we
the Commission proposed to be the level
of 16 billion euros and I think that
breast we have because we have great
scientists we are really superpower in
making high quality satellites and I
know that the technology exists which is
need to build these new satellites put
it up there and I'm sure they will get
the high quality and very precise
information so let me just remind our
viewers you wanted to jump in let me
just remind the viewers that I'm still
looking at what you're sending I'm still
holding this and I in my hand a lot of
comments about how important it is how
happy citizens are that we have those
kind of services how important the
energy transition is a few were
wondering
the outcome of what you experienced in
Katowice maybe you can say a word about
that and one even mentioned so this
maybe I'll give some names to encourage
people to comment this one came I think
it's a Polish name swell swell vermeer
gorge ski was asking about the outcome
in captivity and there was another one
that drew my attention a thicket Spanish
and Jalisco Pelley Ortega who was saying
that according to scientists we only
have 12 years to go back on our path to
leap the climate disaster and I have to
say I heard the Secretary General speak
in Katowice and he did not sound very
optimistic it was a bit alarming so what
is it I think that Secretary General was
right because our scientists just
presented us with very alarming IPCC
report which more or less says that if
you are talking about the climate change
and that overheating of 2 degrees
Celsius we just can forget about it
because it's simply too much and our
ambitions are to laws we have to really
develop our scenarios how to keep the
overheating or planet closer to 1.5
degrees Celsius people felt like they
were almost died that I think that that
that people felt it in in the room
definitely all those who came to cut off
it say but at the same time I think that
it's a message which we have to repeat
permanently because the people who are
in the room they are well informed but I
think that the future of the mankind
let me so dramatic would really depends
what kind of life choices we are ready
to make because we can set the framework
we can bring in the new technologies but
the new lifestyle must be braced by the
by the people and therefore I mean that
the outreach is so important therefore
that if for information is so crucial
there now and also the pictures we get
from satellites to show how ice capsule
are melting how the desert if occasion
is progressing or or what is the air
pollution in our cities because this is
I think one of the strongest mobilizing
factors that people sometimes might be
hesitant to think about what happened 50
years from now but when I see on the
smartphone's that it's dangerous to let
the kids to the street
because the the pollution levels are so
high that they actually can get some
respiratory disease this is what gets
people moving and I believe that this
would help also to to mobilize our
people to be more ambitious if it comes
to crime and it's really we spoke a lot
about climate but you just touched air
pollution and we had a comment I think
it was on Facebook from georgette Seema
and she says I'm in Bucharest and we're
suffering from high pollution and if I
understand correctly
Copernicus does not only climate it has
a lot of different services as one of
them is indeed checking their quality of
air so you do it we do it in combination
of call the satellites are very
important but we also have the earth
station and already with a V the current
technology in a Copernicus we can get
pretty good information pretty precise
that what is the level of the air
pollution but with this future
satellites we are currently working on I
think we can actually pin down their
pollution also not only to the place but
also to the source well it mostly comes
from and I think this would be very very
important for the future because it
would mobilize the people but it will
also put much more pressure on us
policymakers to set up the policies
which are definitely much better not
only for the environment but for the
health of our population I apologize you
wanted to jump in earlier and we get
drifted away which is the case for the
atmosphere monitoring is that he also
require a ground-based element and
modeling in these exercises and actually
I think that's what's very nice about
this co2 initiative it brings together a
whole cross section across Europe of
scientists or people working in the
satellite industry it brings science to
something that's very very policy
relevant and I think in order to stay at
the forefront of this kind of effort
this is what Europe also needs to keep
pushing so make the policy relevant
science also the basic science I would
say but to have this cross community
activities to really push these things
for me pragmatic because we're also here
to try to pitch new ideas to the
vice-president anybody watching us but
also you in the studio so your idea is
what to try to bring scientists more
together and
to have a spillover effect between space
and climate and other fields this what
you're saying that's a good example when
it's working well together but I think
just in general all of these things you
can't just see them in isolation like
the satellites in isolation or the
ground-based measurements or the
entrepreneur's in isolation or the
scientists you have to have structures
in place that allow all these to
interact with each other and I think
there are a lot of structures like that
in place but it's also a matter of
communicating them maybe to wider
community than today forward but I think
from Jessica you mentioned that you work
with scientists from other fields also
in the framework of Copernicus I mean is
this the kind of ideas that you're
looking at or things are in place but I
think they can also just be reinforced
I'm very lucky for example I work for a
Research Center the humanitarian centre
climate change where we are coming from
very different disciplines and we try to
integrate everything but as Freya was
saying and to restate what the Vice
President was mentioning the keys again
information there are providers of
information in these open data policies
actually helped us both the research
community but also the Entrepreneurship
community and now we are in the position
of creating the so called climate
services there are every product into
the transform raw climate data into
useful and usable information to support
decision-making at any level in every
sector and there are a bunch of examples
that are actually supported by European
initiatives such as the horizon 2020
framework or Copernicus climate change
service which there in Des Moines use
cases that they support the development
the use and the transformation of these
data into something that can really be
relevant at decision making levels
raising awareness to the private sector
to businesses so that they know that
this data exists and that they can
actually make use of it how did you find
out about the existence of Copernicus
data because your company you're one of
the co-founders yeah so when you founded
the company I finally correctly the
entire business model is based with if
it weren't for Copernicus your company
wouldn't exist as it does oh there are
not only from Europe but Copernicus has
made a change in the quality where and
acquainted with this do you remember
back when you started following what the
European Center for short-term weather
forecast is doing so we we follow what
what the the innovation is so I don't
know exactly when we start to her about
Copernicus but it was long time before
the project was a reality when we start
to see in the presentation in the
conference in the technical workshop
that the European Commission has founded
this project and these are the results
we were waiting and we were ready the
first day to download the data so and
they know it present so far I hear do
more of what you're doing already
cooperating cause climate services we've
been testing them for a while but they
are in full service operations since
since summer and I see how useful it is
and we've been discussing with Jill that
when I was in this went company
headquarters in in Pamplona very you
have companies like like Siemens Oksana
so they really based this business on
the forecast of the of the wind current
and what today you can do with the
technologies like Joel just just
presented that you have in the middle of
the room big globe and by the arrows you
can actually see how the wind situation
is now what there will be in one hour in
two hours in in five hours it's so
crucial not only for the success of the
company but it's very important for
something which is called intermittency
of renewables that sometimes you might
have it means it means that it's
actually those who would resolve it to
the satisfaction they will get the holy
grail of renewable energies what I mean
by that because wind it's a little bit
of course less predictable than the
solar solar power and when the windmills
are supplying the energy you do not have
the guarantee that it would be the same
intensity all the time so you have
volatility in the system but if you can
pray
dictate what would be the output what
would be the power projection so you can
combine that output of the electricity
also with other sources and then to
so-called balance the tension in the
grid and of course it helps the
companies to provide the complex
services so to have that forecast for by
one hour by one day helps you to plan
better to work with other companies to
offer the good services to the customer
so it's very very crucial and I'm sure
that in the future especially when the
windmills would be also combined with
the possibilities to store energy bit in
batteries or in hydrogen or in some
other media then I think we would be
much closer to what I'm sure more and
more Europeans wants to have really
emission less power power generation and
and to have climate climate neutral
economy yeah the road that project like
Copernicus have in the wind industry is
important to mention the offshore wind
energy energy that is obviously the
future for Europe and the rest of the
world especially now that we are having
the floating wind turbines start to be
there so I mean offshore we don't
measure because it's very expensive it's
hugely expensive to put a wind Mastan on
the middle of the sea so we rely on
technology like satellite like
Copernicus or on our models as well so
this is a must without without that we
couldn't be able to explore the remote
see if you look at that project which is
now very much promoted by the Western
European countries the so-called North
Sea offshore grid so that the idea is to
have there 100 gigawatts of wind power
installation which is which is really
huge and for that to make such a
investment decision you must have very
precise picture what is the wind current
how what would be the return or the
investment and that especially as you
said in offshore area without proper
information from satellites it would be
impossible so it sounds like there's a
lot of spillover between different
sectors and indeed we had a question
from within the house from the energy
services here in the Kerr in the
Commission Margaret Gaza was asking how
do we make sure that we even we spoke
about communicating it to others but
even we ourselves we make sure that we
always use that
comes from satellites so she happens to
work in energy but you know we have
services in the commission for
agriculture for security for border
control how do we make sure that we make
use of that kind of satellite data and
implement it wherever it's relevant in
our policymaking I think we realized
that this commission that if you want
really to make the breakthrough in this
very complex policymaking that we we
need to get rid of the silos and be
really very cross-disciplinary and that
was the idea behind the teams and - the
idea behind the energy union when I was
actually very privileged that my team I
had 14 commissioners a lot of friends I
had to have a lot of coffees with them
to agree on the on the policies on the
legislative proposals one out of 28 one
commissioner Perkins just so how very
much intertwine it is that because I
think it's exactly what we discuss here
the this what do you have in your team
what kind of I mean I mean we have of
course the energy climate Commissioner
the Commissioner responsible for
industry and space then of course trade
agriculture commissioner is possible for
for the for the high season and and
fisheries and and for environment and I
can go on and on and on because it is
one way to make sure they speak to each
other and that they work together I
would say we speak to each other what is
even more important is it was I think
the question which was asked by
margarita to make sure that services
talk to each other because that's
sometimes even more conservative then
then then the commissioners just to
simply make it very clear from the
beginning that we approach it as a
common task there shouldn't be just you
know one by section of the policies and
another one because then of course it
might happen in then it or not so
efficient or as we had it in the past
that sometimes the policies are
contradictory to each other so we we try
to make sure that we'll bring this
teamwork and kind of political steer
only at the beginning of the process and
then ask services to work together and
to bring us something which we can then
present as I joined therefore and as the
results of our common policies because
today not to benefit from all that new
technologies that new information and
from the need to cooperate it would
really be a big mistake and I think we
started like this and I'm sure the next
Commission will come - how has it worked
out for you after almost the end of the
mandate I think that the only anxiety I
have right now before I can say energy
Union mission accomplished because we
will really deliver on all the promises
and commitments we included in the
energon strategy in February 2015 is
actually the picture which is behind you
and that's the clean clean mobility
package because we have few months left
and I hope we'll be able to agree on the
new emission standards for cars whence
trucks and buses because we are already
little belaying lagging behind
surprise surprise behind Chinese who
became the biggest producers of electric
cars and electric buses and I think we
should claim back really the leadership
in this segment as well okay I think the
audience is waking up I have Kara Lublin
tempo is that how you pronounce it in
Italian
one one tempo and he commented both in
YouTube when I'm linked tell Andi stress
is the fact that it's critical that the
data is free I think you Jill also
mentioned the this aspect of copernicus
which is so important for you he's also
making a point about the fact that you
must keep funding this this fundamental
research and program so I think Carly if
you're still watching us the
vice-president was also voicing his I
hope that the nude budget is going to
come across as as it was proposed what
else do we have for you there are some
comments about the international
cooperation around Copernicus so we
mentioned it was a European project it
was yells love music was asking no sorry
I'm going to go back to you I was living
with someone else now I'm getting
confused in my questions but how do we
work with other parts of the world okay
say we can we're just a couple of
examples for the climate change service
we have place cooperation with NOAA so
we have a monthly telephone conferences
with them to discuss what they work on
but we are back on and also have some
projects in common with them actually so
not only not in that case on satellites
but on in situ so ground-based
measurements too
try to put these together so the
archives they have of kind of rescuing
data and we have we're working on that
with them but then of course American
national oceanographic and atmospheric
agency exactly and for satellites so if
we look at for instance some of the
Copernicus products from the climate
change service we do repress this thing
is called of satellites to get a
long-term continuous record and that's
partly based on satellites in space
we're working with a with our partners
and I heard your vice president say that
it was very much appreciated by in some
of your meetings around the world mostly
by Americans who thanked you for the
Copernicus I mean it was of course I'm
trying to I studied at Stanford so I
tried to return back every three for it
just to see what's new in Silicon Valley
and to go to see the partners from from
NASA and from all these big tech
companies and of course I mean you feel
very proud as a European later you know
in this data we get from your satellites
is really based on the planets high
quality we are so happy we can we can
share it with you and then they tell you
that in how many very concrete cases it
helped them and I think in the cases
like we have now the fires in California
or some rescue missions at the sea so
they evil that we can actually help in
that respect is is very very important I
and I just learned before coming to the
studio that we are talking today a lot
about climate change but actually number
one user in this house of our satellite
services is our emergency DG ICO because
usually when we have some weather lady
disaster there first of course to get
the phone call is something very bad is
happening can we have your satellite
maps can we have a prediction some
modeling what will happen tomorrow how
dangerous it is and I think he Europeans
are play playing really the the leading
role globally to be first I would say
not only on the side but the first we
information to know what kind of
dimension of this disaster is and how I
would say the global community can come
to the question we had earlier about our
services talking to each other so here
we have very different services one
which is doing humanitarian aid and
civil protection another one is running
satellites in space because they make
sure that the data from space reaches
those who need it here in providing
action so in the end as you mentioned
the silos our breaking yeah to some
extent and if I understood what you were
saying before Europe is quite autonomous
today we are the one providing the data
to the rest of the world but we also
working in cooperation so there's a fine
balance there between being independent
but also making sure that we reinforce
each other we have to work together say
we also work together with wma for
instance as a World Organization for the
World Meteorological Organization I
don't know if you saw that statement
just before the cup it's a statement
about the state of the climate that 2018
is likely to be one of the fourth
warmest years on record and there
Copernicus and other European partners
provide data to that but I think in
order to have a comprehensive view you
also need to cooperate with others and
just for the sake of justice of
different services and space programs
out there that the EU does I feel like
we speak a lot about Copernicus but
there's also Galileo and EGNOS which are
quite big and I feel like they're also
relevant for this discussion about
climate change and an energy transition
or vice president I mean I think Gallo
definitely because I think in a next
decade we would be in very privileged
position because actually in Europe we
would be able to provide the most
precise localization services on this
planet so we'll be talking
civilian use 20 centimeters and you know
and it's actually very very important
because today we are depending of course
on the quality of the signal somewhere
between 7 to 10 meters so it makes you
can imagine what
- 10 - 20 cents 20 cents what kind of
difference it might have for for example
visual impaired people because I saw one
startup from Spain and they're actually
developing the the app that with the
goggle services that can actually
navigate the the people across across
the the streets and is narrow Alban
Canyon with a big precision because you
satellites also in space similar to
Copernicus but instead of taking selfies
of Earth
I'm just taking pictures of us they
provide us with geolocalization
geolocalization they are providing us
with app with the process precise
timekeeping because they have this very
precise atomic clock and we use them
from everything from time stepping on
banking transactions to the precise
localization of the planes for safe
landing we need it I mean we calculated
that I mean if it comes to localization
and navigation services almost 10% of
the European GDP depends on on this
infrastructure therefore have be very
much pushed for having this I would say
geostrategic autonomy having our own
system because if somebody would switch
it off II real it would be in a deep
trouble imagine all the trucks planes
ships which are now absolutely dependent
on localization services if I understand
correctly both Copernicus and Galileo
are fairly new services in operation we
are kind of lucky that we managed to
launch to put up there the new
generation of satellites which comes to
navigation services or to the air of the
Russian service we can actually provide
the best quality because their their
newer satellites but of course it would
be very important to keep it up to
replace them when it's needed when the
new technology comes and can provide
better services just to keep just to
keep that leading leading position and
there's one more word on on Galileo we
are talking a lot about emissions about
transport about the fact that from
transport emissions we get 25 percent of
greenhouse gases I mean on on the planet
so just imagine that when we would be
able to use that data better for more
precision logistic for bed
use of trucks for more precise routing
of our planes and for better planning of
the of the public transport all this
should be possible and with connected
automated driving we can even make the
leap forward and really to reduce by the
new technologies the greenhouse gas
emissions are all different technologies
to describe from autonomous driving to
our phones which are also using geo
localization they all depend in the end
on satellites and they could depend on
EU satellites whether it's Galileo or
Copernicus Galileo for navigation
localization Copernicus for Earth
Observation so Copernicus started and
instead for services this year can you
narrow is still in initial services new
services coming in the sky dela offered
the early services already I mean it was
my my plea when I was in Kourou and
we've been launching the new set of
satellites whom I play with the with the
scientific community there was please
give us the Christmas present and offer
us the early services and they they
actually did so it happen and we will
have the already now I mean you have all
the new smartphones that already
equipped with the chips for garel also I
think we have currently 400 million
users of the delocalization service so
it's quite significant and we will have
the the full constellation of 30
satellites up there by 2020 so it's
fairly new infrastructure very important
one our high quality and I think that
it's good also through this transmission
to underline the fact that this is the
infrastructure which belongs to the
Europeans both Copernicus and satellites
it's the European infrastructure funded
by EU money someone even as dementia aim
is quoted him earlier Yaroslav misiek
west earlier on youtube if we know the
economic value generated by climate
services so I don't know if anybody has
that figure from the top of their heads
but these are very significant you
answer him you will be very happy market
the
estimates but I'm not gonna say a number
because if I say a number I will be
creative for that and I will be creative
probably I can say that it's not for
climate change but I can say that one
person that we are able to reduce on the
uncertainty of the feasibility of a wind
farm can have an impact of 1 million
euro
1% 1% that we are able to reduce
uncertainty on the wind speed the
certainty the certainty the bias okay
so reducing the error of 1% in wind
energy in the wind energy or wind
project that is in development can have
an impact of 1 million euro on a typical
one 100 megawatts you farm this is a
number just to give you an idea what how
important is for us that Copernicus
become better in the new version etc
because now we are not just working for
providing data for Europe that more or
less we know the resources but we are
providing data for China for India for
Africa respect a lot in Africa win
energy in the future so it's important
that we are able to reduce uncertainty
I'm getting screams in my headphones we
need to start concluding soon I allow
myself one last question because I'm an
AI geek I really like artificial
intelligence I think it's mind blowing
you're producing so much data were you
nearing the phase when we won't need
people to actually interpret that data
but basically an algorithm would replace
UGL and will tell us where we need to
plant those windmills and we will be
able to find those trends within the
data or am I now again throwing a bomb
other fields working on space data but
what I can tell is the machine learning
were a I are huge supporting supporting
all this movement and they're very
relevant for technology there are
supporting also the creation of climate
services and the processes of data the
use of data including every possible
source of satellite we like them too a
lot because they're actually supporting
quite significantly but it's also
important to engage the user in this
process to communicate to the user the
science that is behind because it's not
just the satellite
or the space technology but there is
quite some relevant science that has
been going on in the past decades in
that science enters into a user-friendly
product in a way that the user can
understand it but without any limit or
barrier and that is the incredible work
that go viral collectively we are trying
to do totally fascinating ok we need to
start concluding so I don't know if you
want to have last words each of you and
then I let the vice-president tell us
how he feels about this exercise video
wanted to say something maybe just
underline with chills set about the wind
farms and knowing when you do the
planning you need to be climate smart
invent so it's not only in the wind puns
about knowing what's happening tomorrow
you can kind of steer am I going to put
this use this station or not but
actually when you plan it you need to
know not only in general it's cold and
rainy in the in the UK or in the south
of Sweden but how often are you likely
to have peaks of wind power forecasting
when it's decades ahead but to try to
project for wind this difficult for
temperature it's well Jill is almost
there we look back in time but we are so
interested in what's happened in the
future so my comparison is that we
industry is the main user of copernicus
Europe has a target to that the 30% of
more of the electric demand in 2040 came
from from the wind so we need to pass
many barriers but one very important is
to have good information to make the
accellerated project earth or from space
wherever it comes from but in a global
market like the wind industry we need
global information better basically more
sources ok so Jessica do you want to I
feel like you bring all different hats
here you're a you're a founder of
of a start-up and your researcher and
you're a trainer and you're doing a bit
of everything so what's your conclusion
of this discussion this is possible
because the word is going to or my
suggestion in a way is also to foster
these this cooperation between the two
communities of space and climate by
fostering the human mobility schemes
fostering the interaction across sectors
of scientists that can get can get
together and build something new and
innovative the mantra of our startup is
get shift done and it looks very looks
very done because it's important to use
this information to make the shift
toward the climate smart word and
Copernicus climate change service is
super helpful
Hinda so I really look forward to see
what happened next
definitely ok vice-president how was
this for you know I fascinating and it
just I think proved what I always knew
that we have great young people in
Europe who are excellent in what they do
that we have a lot of innovative minds
we have a lot of innovative ideas and
what we have to do is to make sure that
then people would go for vacations
travel but they would stay here and
develop the ideas in Europe they they
don't have to go overseas to Silicon
Valley to China to develop the ideas
related to space and climate because I
think in this case we are quite
privileged in Europe that we have the
strongest public support for the climate
policies everywhere else it's much more
difficult so let's use that support
let's use these bright minds and I think
the practical advice like be hard from
Francesca gets you've done and you have
even more mergers between space climate
and I would say all other climate
related policies would be great and I
think we just need to find even more
user-friendly mechanisms how we can
really support
the young people is such a bride ears
like you had with us today okay so on
this very optimistic note of getting
shift done all over Europe let me thank
all of you Francesca vice-president Jill
and fair and thank you for watching us
and for sending your comments if this
was useful for you for free to share it
who knows maybe someone else in your
community is also a space climate geek
and will appreciate that have a lively
have a lovely evening from all of us
here in Brussels thank you and goodbye
you
you
[Music]
you